hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making
big the show where i make giant food for
my friends
one thing i've always wanted to make on
this show was
the krabby patty so my friend andrew ray
who you guys might be familiar with
is the creator of the babish kleiner
universe he sent me
a challenge video so let's take a look
alvin andrew here from binging with
babish you know who i am you've been
here
in my house i hear you're back to your
old tricks again making gigantic food
and whatnot
and i'd like to challenge you to make a
giant version of one of the most popular
recipes
of all time from my show the krabby
patty now i maintain that the secret
ingredient in the krabby patty
is nothing they have a burger that
creates its own viral marketing campaign
the krabby patty
is an enigma so to make something
satisfactory for our audience we gotta
just try and load it up with as many
underseat mommy
ingredients as possibly maybe grind the
umami ingredients
into the beef and nobody really knows
what's in the krabby patty the only
thing i know it's not in the krabby
patty is
crab because it'd be kind of [ __ ] up
right it'd be good to have mr crab
serving burgers made from crab that's
barbaric so load it up
make it big i can't wait to see it well
andrew had a lot of great things to say
i think we're going to start with making
the bun
so this is actually a recipe by the
great joshua weissman
this is his burger bun recipe check them
out
all right so i put some yeast and sugar
in some milk
let the yeast get nice and bubbly yeast
will
start to grow up right before our very
eyes
they grow up so fast don't they that's
what my mom used to say
she's she's still said she's here she
still says that while that's going i'm
going to make
what's called a tangjong it's
essentially a
milk bread inspired recipe so i'm
putting in
milk some flour and some water gonna
give that a nice stir
essentially this kind of makes like a
milky roux kind of situation it's gonna
give the bread
some really nice textures so this
mixture is getting kind of thick
as you can see it's like a very milky
paste but i think
this is good to go all right i'm
bringing in todd
so we have our good friend todd back in
the fray in
a bowl red flower don't spill stop
spilling alvin classic salt and
this very dangerously bubbly yeast
mixture
all right and you go and we're gonna go
slow
all right this dough is coming together
i'm gonna put in the the flour paste
i'm gonna go in with the eggs there we
go this is a stiff dough
well as you can see i'm bracing this
mixer with my entire body
he seems to be having a very very
difficult time
oh he's working hard i'm gonna add in
the butter
we're gonna turn the speed to low and he
shut off
we're gonna give him a little break
todd's pissed he's very hot
let him cool down a bit and then you
know we'll talk because we can't resolve
these problems right now
and now we're going to slowly add in
butter i think he's ready for some more
butter
all right no more butter there you go
okay last bit here we go again
i hope this table doesn't break i'm
gonna call this done just because uh
this is very hot but i think we can make
our bun
into this bowl all right get out of
there
hey i should stop doing that do that too
much actually give this guy
a nice flip and i think
we're good this dough baby gonna take a
nice nap and then
we're gonna keep making the crab patty
well it seems like my dough has
gotten quite large kinda looks like me
after a big meal time to punch it down
[Music]
anyways this comes out onto the board
i'm trying to get this
roughly all patched up into a ball shape
so then i can turn it over
this is a beautiful dough baby we're
gonna get him into this ring
just a warning this is not how you
handle babies don't do this
okay here we go to the oven
so as andrew specifically mentioned in
his challenge video the secret
ingredient to krabby patty could
either be nothing which is very smart or
he also mentioned
that we could do a custom powder based
on things you might find
in the sea so first i'm gonna put some
kombu just dried seaweed or kelp into a
spice grinder ah you know i feel like
this makes sense
you know mr krabs has a wealth of these
resources about him bonito flake which
is dried fish flakes some dry shiitake
mushrooms and one
little anchovy this is the fish that got
on mr krabs bad side don't do that he he
tried to steal the recipe so he became a
part of the recipe wow that's dark
anyways i'm gonna spice grind these now
that's fun this is looking okay
that's a wow look at that i'm just gonna
sift this it smells very like c
c seafoody like the seed
smells good it's just out of my nose
so the krabby patty is still a burger
and
based on andrew's recipe and his show he
likes to make the burger from scratch
which i also do
as well so we have a lot of beautifully
marbled short ribs and we have chuck
chopped into nobody saw that chunks
and semi frozen here we go
put too much we're gonna do this in
batches just like andrew does in his
videos which
is the correct way to do it i did not
listen
oh that's better yeah all right
nice and pebbly oh that's beautiful look
at that i'm very happy with this
and this isn't all the beef this is just
the small batch as you can see it's
going to take quite a while but grinding
beef so
we will be back
well after a lot of help from the
culinary team we have
25 pounds of ground meat
it is time to season andrew said putting
the seafood powder directly in the meat
could add that extra flavor so that's
what i'm going to do
go in oh look at that there we go
ground pepper and salt all right
i think this is going to be my workout
for the day here we go oh boy here
yep
we'll be right back
okay well this has been sufficiently
mixed let's see if i can do this
oh my god
that's heavy
let's get this guy into a nice shape i
want to make sure there's no big
air pockets seal this guy up i've never
seen this much beef before oh except
sometimes unlike
you know random like twitter drama this
is like the comment section right here i
don't use twitter so i don't really know
if that's true
let's do some final seasoning i know
already seasoned inside but
if i make a burger i'm going to season
the outside
just to get a nice you know flavor salt
from very up high covers it evenly
and you know some pepper
careful album that's a lot of pepper i
think it's safe to say
that this 25 pound patty is
sufficiently ready and he's gonna go
into the oven
here we go oh my lord
time to go
oh god my arms are so tired
[Music]
i think also andrea on his show for
babish makes custom tea slices so we're
gonna make a custom
american-ish style cheese so first i'm
gonna bloom
gelatin in some milk and now i'm going
to
heat up some milk and butter so this
butter and milk
nice and melted so we can move on
all right bring back the whole the food
processor
in here it's going to dump in a lot of
teas
slow and steady wins the race is what a
loser would say
so we're just gonna yeah we're spilling
that's okay
okay now i'm gonna put the salt in and
it's gonna quickly pulse this
until calms down a bit
okay and then into this milk and butter
situation
gelatin is nice and bloomed we're gonna
get all this
plop in there just so that we don't keep
spilling because that seems to be the
theme of this show
i'm gonna pour the milk and gelatin
mixture into this cup
there's a high probability i'm still
gonna spill
no spill it's like a cheese smoothie
wow yeah that's definitely
cheese okay this is done look at that
that's beautiful
oh wow this is like a paste it smells
delicious i kind of want to eat it with
like nachos i'm very happy with this
technique
wow that's satisfying it's like frosting
a cake
except there's no cake it's a burger all
right well up
yeah here we have it a giant cheese
slice this is gonna go chill
in the fridge so the gelatin can set and
then i think we are going
to start assembling i really hope
andrew's excited for this because
just look at this man
well well well seems like we have a very
large
burger bun wow look at this dude let's
carefully
wiggle wiggle wiggle
nice all right
this is wild okay here we go oh
it's very soft all right just some
trimming on the bun
as all good burgers the buns should be
toasted
because they don't have a toaster this
big i'm just gonna do it this way
some melted butter crush that on and
we're gonna toast it
i'm not sure if a krabby patty's buns
are toasted maybe they can't toast it
because they're underwater although that
logic would kind of invalidate the whole
restaurant idea i also don't know where
they would get butter there are no cows
then again i guess there's no beef so
then they can't we're not really using
logic
on this show today we're just making
giant food and having a good time
well i have a heat gun and a dream
takes quite a while to toast the bun
with the heat gun so
i'm going to be here for quite a while
[Music]
so uh with the help of my teammates this
uh bun is now successfully toasted
it smells incredible highly recommend
toasting your buns
anyways this right here is the cheese
slice
i'm gonna remove it patty's almost done
cheese is here i think it's time to make
a krabby patty
so you might be wondering what is under
this delicately blanketed packages
and well i don't know why i'm talking
like this it's the patty
it's been baking for like an hour and a
half it's time to finally see what we
got
dang that's a big patty and then now
the big question is alvin how are you
gonna get
this patty onto the bun but i found a
tool
more like a weapon here we go so juicy i
love it it means there's a lot of flavor
oh boy i don't know if i'm physically
strong enough to do this to be quite
honest
i don't know if these spatulas are
either i have two hands
three spatulas how's this gonna work i
have no clue
but we will try oh my god it's so
heavy wow i think it's time to put on
the cheese slice
oh this is soft i might have to like
completely flip this over
fingers crossed i guess all right one
two three whoa
well the cheese is on i guess well we
have our condiments laid out we have
pickles lettuce
tomatoes onions ketchup um with some msg
for that umami flavor and miso mustard i
want to see if i can
get the cheese to melt a little bit
smells so good
all right we'll just do the lettuce then
we're gonna do tomatoes next
now i'm going to put the onions all
right pickles
last two condiments some ketchup so miso
mustard all right
the bun is going on careful alvin don't
mess this up i think this is it this is
a
it's like a 40 pound krabby patty wow
look at that
okay final touch the sesame seeds gonna
glue them on
with a little bit of honey not sure if
this will work but
oh it one fell already that's okay
ah nice one skilled dollop
stick he stick since i'm doing these all
by hand
i may be here for quite a while so final
touches
and then andrew should be here and well
our special guest is here welcome back
to the tasty studio andrew thanks for
having me dude so you sent me that video
in the morning and uh we spent the day
making a giant krabby patty you know
follow the instructions
i'm very excited to see what you made
man i've never been made big before
all right well without further ado one
two three take a look
holy sh look at the size of that what
are the sesame seeds they're
the little pieces of white bread that i
cut out because
they don't grow them like that um the
beef is your recipe also from your
basics burger episode
it was 25 pounds of meat like no kidding
jesus most expensive episode we've done
oh the burger has the seafood powder so
bonito
kelp dried anchovy shiitake we kind of
made that but yeah lettuce tomatoes
onions just like mr krabs says we did
miso mustard like yours
okay some umami ketchup did you remember
the pickles always if i
i would take this top off but there are
pickles underneath this bun
because i was about to go bubble bath on
you i just got really scared for a
second
uh anyway do you want to actually come
here and take a look we'll switch sides
let's do it all right let's see what we
got here may i touch it may do things to
it it's technically yours
how are these adhered a little bit of
honey nice yeah
how do i eat would you like me to cut
you a slice
i think we should get a cross section of
this thing godspeed alvin thank you
this knife is vertical yeah that knife
is not the size of that burger
all right here we go let's see oh my god
it's properly cooked i don't believe it
look at that look at that it's like what
medium rare ish that's a that's a
solid medium to medium row which is
astonishing considering the size of that
burger
let's eat some yeah would you like this
hat thank you oh i get my own half
what i'm going to do is i'm going to try
to assemble myself like an actual bite
yeah me too tomato lettuce i'm just
making sure i have all the
horses i respect that please there we go
all right i got myself a bite here here
we go well cheers cheers
thank you thank you
does it taste like something mr krabs
would serve at his restaurant
i'm gonna give that a big old giant yes
just like your big old giant
burger my friend that tastes like the
krabby patty when i made it that's all i
need to hear
better even and bigger thanks for coming
in andrew thanks for
making this thing man this is crazy it's
huge it's delicious
it's a work of art it's making it big
and well with that being said thank you
andrew for coming in
i don't know why he's frozen because
he's lagging a little bit it's freeze
frame
freeze oh freeze frame please check out
andrew's channel a lot of cool stuff
uh going on there i made a video with
him once that was very fun and yeah
thanks for coming in we'll see you guys
next time bye
you